bonsoir cnit oran merci d'être avec nous
alors la nouvelle évidemment qui vous
concerne vassaux également
l'ile-de-france pas confiné à le
week-end c'est une confirmation ce soir
c est un vrai soulagement du côté de son
également un soulagement peut-être pas
parce que nous avions effectivement
discuter de tout cela avec le préfet bon
je pense que la mesure qui a été prise
et plutôt plutôt une bonne mesure mais
je ne voudrais pas que ceci ne lance un
message trop positif auprès de notre
population de nos populations
parce qu'il faut continuer naturellement
comme l'a dit le premier ministre il y
aurait respecté les gestes barrière le
port du masque les jauges dans les
commerces c'est très important aussi et
et faire en sorte que les grands
rassemblements n'existe pas donc il ya
encore beaucoup de pédagogie beaucoup
d'accompagnement à faire pour nos
concitoyens faut pas s'imaginer que
parce qu'il n'ya pas de confinement on
peut faire comme avant c'est vraiment un
message important ça je trouve qu'il
faut que nous fassions attention mais
évidemment c'est une vie un peu moins
difficiles qui s'annoncent pour nos
concitoyens avec notamment le maintien
de l'ouverture des parcs et jardins
le maintien de l'ouverture des écoles
c'est aussi quelque chose qui est très
important auquel nous tenons beaucoup
alors le pas de calais c'est pas la même
chose
certains élus d'ailleurs ne comprennent
pas ce deux poids deux mesures vous êtes
également on l'a dit responsable au sein
de l'association des maires de france
vous comprenez un petit peu la colère de
nos amis du nord / jantes j'entends ce
qu'a dit notamment mon collègue de
daniel fasquelle que je connais bien
l'association des maires de france à a
toujours souhaité que soit soit
territorialisée les mesures donc nous
nous comprenons aussi et nous sommes
d'accord pour dire qu' il peut y avoir
ponctuellement pendant quelques semaines
des mesures différentes d'un territoire
à l'autre d'ailleurs c'est le cas à nice
aussi il n'ya pas que le pas de calais
yao s'initient à dunkerque et là comme
vous l'avez vu les élus étaient plutôt
d'accord avec ça donc
bon je pense que bon tout ceci est une
affaire de réglages mais je pense que
nous pensons que les mesures tarifaires
réalisées c'est plutôt bien parce que on
voit bien que la situation ne veut pas
dire que demain par exemple pas de
calais pourrait être des conflits nés
complètement alors que l'île de france
où une partie de l'ile-de-france
pourrait être donc au plus confiné tout
dépend de la façon dont les choses vont
évoluer
c'est une crise que nous n'avons jamais
connu que aucun gouvernement
l'inconnu et donc il est assez normal je
trouvais assez naturel que le
gouvernement donc géré ça un petit peu
donc un peu à vue mais pas comment faire
autrement pour faire en sorte de ne pas
doubler la crise sanitaire par une crise
économique c'est déjà un peu le cas et
surtout par une crise morale parce que
c'est là où est le sujet voilà donc je
pense que les mesures qui sont prises
sont plutôt adaptée à la situation
le moral parlons-en parce que le couvre
feu de 18h c'est pas terrible non plus
soyons honnêtes nous appelait d'ailleurs
eu à le retarder d'une heure inscrire
les informations sont bonnes pour
quelles raisons oui tout à fait nous
avons alors j'étais allé un des premiers
à le dire mais enfin les maires des
hauts-de-seine notamment ont demandé aux
préjugés d'examiner de fermenter l'idée
de pouvoir décaler le couvre-feu en
effet à 19 heures la raison en est
simple c'est que nous avons constaté
dans nos villes dans les commerces et
supermarchés qui avait quand même
beaucoup de monde entre 17 heures et 18
heures parce que évidemment les gens
puisque en fait on continue quand même à
travailler les enfants continuerait à
l'école donc forcément il y a le rythme
de la vie fait qu' un certain nombre de
démarches de course etc ne peuvent être
faites que le à ce moment là et donc
c'est trop court cette période est trop
court et nous pensons que la vraie lutte
en fait contre l'avis la diffusion des
virus c'est d'éviter les rassemblements
d'éviter des concentrations de personnes
ça c'est le sujet numéro un est bien
pour éviter ça il faut étaler sur une
heure et demie à deux heures
la fin de journée pour que les gens
puissent faire leurs courses plus
tranquillement
philippe laurent
heureusement vous n'avez pas été entendu
ce soir et c'est vrai qu'on l'a tous
constaté voilà la queue au supermarché à
18 heures tous mentent assez pour se
dépêcher
le vendredi soir c'est vrai que c'est
quoi c'est un gouvernement hors sol qui
ne sais pas voilà ce que c'est on
simplement peut-être d'aller faire les
courses et de vivre comme tout à chacun
d'aller chercher ses enfants à l'école
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
non je n'irai pas jusque là mais je
dirais que nous allons continuer à faire
entendre notre voix auprès du
gouvernement pour lui de lui suggéré
d'examiner avec attention une plus
grande attention encore notre
proposition qui nous paraît être une
proposition de bon sens et qu'il ne
remet pas en question les principes même
des règles que qu'il a lui-même fixé et
dont nous partageons donc la grotte de
la grande majorité
donc on va continuer à dire que en tout
cas pour ce qui concerne la région
parisienne ou en vie enfin on est un peu
en décalage peut-être par rapport à des
agglomérations de province à en revendre
plus tard et c'est bon on va continuer à
lui dire au gouvernement que il nous
paraît que 19 heures c'est mieux que 18
heures voilà alors un autre sujet on
espère peut-être un autre sujet qui met
parfois en porte à faux les maires de
france c'est la vaccination il ya
beaucoup de personnes âgées même on
entendait un témoignage tout à l'heure
85 ans qui a du mal à avoir un rendez
vous l'objectif de jean castex d'un
million de personnes vaccinées d'ici la
mi mai vous ne vous y croyez à cet
objectif qui semble à ce jour un petit
peu il réalisable en tout cas oui c'est
vrai que si on prend le rythme actuel
est qu'on le prolonge naturellement ne
dérive pas donc il faut vraiment
accéléré alors sur ce sujet il ya deux
choses qui sont importantes
évidemment c'est d'abord la faune la
fourniture des doses ne maîtrisons pas
nous élus locaux ne maîtrisons pas des
choses ça c'est le gouvernement qui
maîtrise à priori il y à une
accélération de livraison des doses et
notamment le modern a qui arrivent enfin
bref donc il ya une et puis d'autres
vaccins peut être décidée d'ici avril ou
mai donc par conséquent d'assez de
débarrasser le gouvernement qui sait ce
qu'il fait qui c'est lui qui négocie des
achats
deuxième sujet c est ce que nous sommes
capables nous élus locaux avec les
médecins de ville avec les pharmaciens
est ce qu'on est capable d'organiser un
système de fonctionner de vaccinations
de base qui permettent de vacciner
autant de personnes nous nous disons oui
nous disons oui nous avons d'ores et
déjà organisé dans certaines communes
des centres de vaccination qui
fonctionne il ne fonctionne pas à plein
parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de doses mais
pourraient vacciner beaucoup plus et
j'ai cru comprendre que le gouvernement
allait ouvrir allait proposer d'ouvrir
d'autres centres de vaccination je suis
donc moi-même concernés puisque nous
avons proposé avec mes deux villes
président de bourg-la-reine et d'anthony
dont rira centre mutualisé
le gouvernement a donné son accord il a
signé l'arrêté aujourd'hui le centre
déjà le 15 mars
donc on aura une capacité en tout cas à
traiter les vaccins beaucoup plus
importante ça on sait le faire nous les
élus locaux
nous prenons cet engagement un noeud de
mettre en place les conditions
matérielles de mobiliser les
professionnels de santé de nos
territoires pour que ça fonctionne
maintenant le vrai sujet encore une fois
ce sont les doses c'est le gouvernement
journée les doses
on y arrivera merci philippe laurent
maire de sceaux d'avoir été avec mon
direct sur rt france